The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: And I have
put on the second board
just a quick review of
the key equations that we
use to do the direct method.
So straight from Newton's
second law, the first one,
second one-- the summarization
of torques about some point a.
a may be g, in which case
things get much simplified, g
being the center of mass.
And if point a is moving,
then you have this extra term.
And this is a new
equation over here,
which I got frustrated with
this equation a few days ago
and derive something, which
I think is easier to use.
So I'll do a problem today
using that expression.
So I won't talk more about
it now-- show it to you
in a minute.
And then finally, it's
convenient at times
to express angular
momentum with respect
to a point a as angular
momentum about g
plus the position vector from a
to g times the linear momentum.
So that's kind of the
covered on the quiz.
And we're going to
use these equations.
Today, what I'm going to do
is look at a few problems
from the point of view
both equations of motion,
by the direct method
and the Lagrange method,
and kind of talk about and
which one's easier, when should
you choose this one,
when to choose that one.
That's the nature of today's
lecture to sort of get
you prepped for the quiz.
And a little bit more
on generalized forces.
You have questions about
what's going to be on the quiz?
AUDIENCE: What is that
last word-- balancing of?
PROFESSOR: Balancing of rotors.
There's a rotor-- any thing
that we spin about an axis.
A rigid body spinning
about an axis,
you can call a
rotor of some kind.
And balancing is usually--
the axes are fixed.
And so is this one--
this axis passes
through the center
of mass-- so is
this rotor statically balanced?
Right.
Is this rotor
dynamically balance?
Would you expect to
when this is spinning,
it's direction of spin
is vertical, right.
Is the direction of the
angular momentum of this
object in the same direction
as the angle of rotation?
No.
And so that's an indication
of dynamic imbalance.
Angular momentum is not
in the same direction
as angular rotation, right.
All right.
And, well, while
we're on that subject,
we'll just hit it briefly here.
One other prop I need.
So another rigid
body, and I don't know
where g is on this rigid body.
So does-- this is
rotating about an axis.
Is this object
statically balanced,
just doing this experiment?
We're doing an experiment.
We're sticking this
on an axis, and we're
letting it do it's thing.
And I'm asking you is
it statically balance.
How do you know?
AUDIENCE: Because if you were to
flip it upside down and do it,
it would still come to a stop.
PROFESSOR: So it goes
to a low point, right.
And that tells you what about
the position of this axis?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The
center of mass has
got gravity, puts a force
at the center of mass,
creates a torque which
brings it to the low point.
Does this object
have any symmetries
that you could point out?
Or in other words, can you
without doing any math tell me
one principal axis
of this object?
AUDIENCE: Where the dotted line
is, that's a plane [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So you say I've
got a dotted line around here
and that's a plane of what?
AUDIENCE: Plane of symmetry.
PROFESSOR: So there's a
plane of symmetry cutting
this thing through here.
So if you can identify
one plane of symmetry,
then where can you tell
me that for sure you
know that you can
make a principal axis?
He says perpendicular
to that plane.
Any place on that plane
perpendicular to it?
What do you think?
For now, we've identified
it has a plane of symmetry
and that an axis perpendicular
to it-- a principle axis should
be perpendicular to that plane.
But the question is
where do I put it?
Where, perpendicular
to that plane
can this axis be and
be a principal axis?
She says through g.
Do you agree with that?
So certainly through g.
Let's say that that really is
g and I put it through here.
And if it was
exactly through g, it
wouldn't rotate to the low spot.
This is pretty close.
It struggles to get there.
That's definitely a principal
axis, but are there more?
This is kind of the real
point of the question.
Are there other
allowable principal axes
in this direction?
So we haven't talked
about this very much.
Any axis-- if this
is a principal axis,
any axis parallel to
it is a principal axis.
It's no longer through g.
It's no longer statically
balanced about that point.
But it's still a principal axis.
And one measure of
whether or not something
is a principal axis-- if
you know the principal axes
of an object and you write
the mass moment of inertia
matrix of it with
respect to g, what
does that matrix look like?
Where does it have
0s and non-0s?
It's a diagonal matrix.
So if i about g
is diagonal, that
means you're computed
the moment, mass moment
properties with respect
to three principal axes.
If it's diagonal, and those
axes all pass through g,
if I now take one of
those axes and say,
I want to move it
over here, and you've
re-computed the inertia matrix,
would it still be diagonal?
So you've moved just one axis
to another spot, parallel
to its original one.
You know this one
is a principal axis.
I'm going to move
it just parallel.
Only that one axis-- the other
two are saying where they are.
I've just moved it parallel.
Is that also a principal axis,
or another way of saying it,
does that mass matrix, mass
moment of inertia matrix stay
diagonal?
Do any of the
terms in it change?
Let's say this is the z
principal axis and I move away.
So now you have this new
mass moment inertia matrix.
Does the Izz term change?
Yeah, by how much?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: He said ml
squared, l being what?
AUDIENCE: The length you moved.
PROFESSOR: Here.
And that's this thing though
as parallel axis there, right?
If you move one axis, any axis
parallel to one of those axes
is also a principal axis.
So that's a subtle point.
We don't often talking about it.
Any axis parallel to a principal
axis is also principal axis.
Well, let's think
about a problem.
We've done this problem before.
But now we have
all the full tools.
We have Lagrange, we
have direct method.
So that's this problem of the
wheel on a horizontal plane.
Kind of a complicated
distribution of mass
for which we know Izz about g
is some mass radius and gyration
squared.
Maybe we measured it
rather than computed it.
So this thing is sliding
on ice, and it has cord
wrapped around it.
I'm pulling with a
force F, call it F1.
I'll provide the inertial frame.
And it's got some
radius R. And we'll
say the surface is frictionless.
So I don't have a
string wrapped around.
But we're really talking
about this problem.
I'm pulling on the
string and this thing
can slide and rotate.
Take a second.
Think about how
many different ways
can you think of solving for
the equations of motion of this?
So if this on a quiz,
I want you to find
the equations of motion.
What method would you use?
And what's this?
And then you're
confronted with, well,
I know more than one method.
What's the simplest method?
And before that,
you need to decide
how many coordinates
you're going to need,
how many equations you're
going-- so let's start there.
How many independent coordinates
do you need to do this problem?
We'll back up one
more question, then.
Is this a planar motion problem?
So it's confined to one plane.
I see a lot of heads nodding.
And it rotates only with one
degree of freedom of rotation,
axis perpendicular to the plane.
So this is a planar
motion problem.
So in general, planar
motion problems
have found many degrees
of freedom per rigid body?
So I see a bunch of 3's.
Does this one have any
constraints on those three
degrees of freedom?
So this has three
degrees of freedom.
You conceivably need
three equations of motion.
What are the choices
for getting them?
I want you to think
about this for a minute.
You decide what way
you would do, and let's
take a poll in a minute.
You think about it,
and then let's take
a poll for how people
would do this problem.
So what's your favorite?
How would you do it?
He'd use the direct method.
Do you need a torque equation?
About what point?
He'd use center of mass.
So he'd say, direct method
and for the torque equation,
do it about the center of mass.
Anybody have a different way
they would do this problem?
Is there another way to do it?
He wants to do Lagrange.
Everybody agree it
could be done that way?
So I agree, and let's
quickly do this problem.
And so direct method-- I'm going
to make it easier on myself
here.
So the three coordinates,
you're going to need an x, a y,
and a theta is what I've chosen
for the three coordinates
to do this direct method.
And to make it
easy on myself, I'm
going to align the force
with my coordinates.
So I'm going to
essentially make theta 0.
Essentially aligning F1, my
force F1 with the x-axis.
And if I do that, then I can say
the sum of the forces in the y,
the external forces in the y
direction are nonexistent, 0.
So that must be my double
dot, so y double dot is 0.
So that simplifies the problem.
Summation of forces in the
x direction, external forces
are F1I.
And they must equal to the
mass times the acceleration
in the x direction.
And I'm basically done
with that equation.
AUDIENCE: Is that a
rotating [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well, I'm doing this.
I'm saying this is
my inertia frame.
You add an inertial frame?
Sure.
Now I can-- I don't
have to break this force
into components, F1 cosine
theta in the x direction
and F1 sine theta
in the y direction
and get two-- get a finite
amount, a nonzero amount
for y double dot and non-0
amount for x double dot.
I end up with three equations
I have to work with.
Just by realigning it, I can
make this problem even simpler.
So just to do it quickly,
that's what I did.
So I've got two of the
three equations done.
And finally, the sum
of the torques about g.
And we know the angular
momentum of this
would be some izz
g times omega z
would be the angular momentum.
And it's d by dt of that
izz about g, omega z dot,
which is theta
double dot, right?
And what are the
external torques?
So figure it out.
What's the external
torque in this problem?
What is its size and
what's its direction?
So, somebody give me--
what's the external torque
with respect to
where, to start with?
So we're summing torques
about g, the center of mass.
R cross F, right, which
comes out in what direction?
k direction, right?
And minus or plus?
Do your right hand rule.
And notice I've
drawn x and y such
that positive z
is into the board.
So this is positive.
I put a positive z into
the board on purpose
so that this would just work
out R F1 in the k direction.
And that's equal to Izz
about g theta double dot.
And since it's all
with respect to k,
you can drop the
unit vectors here.
And so we have one equation.
We have two equations.
And we have three equations.
And that's all we
need to complete this,
is three degrees of freedom to
completely define the motion.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Do you want us
to have a trivial case?
PROFESSOR: Do you mean the
my double dot equals 0?
Well, in general-- when
I started this one, when
I didn't align them, then you're
forced to use the three, right?
So the only difference
between what
I did and this probe making a
problem slightly more messy,
is if I had let theta, this
angle, be other than 0, I
would have had to have
come up with three
non-zero acceleration equations.
So I'd say technically, or I'd
just say I think it's prudent.
If you're ever not
sure, if you can
look at it and by inspection
write down, my double dot is 0,
you've essentially just
written an equation of motion.
Rather than say
let's just ignore it,
I'd keep it in your-- I'd
just put it on the paper,
my double dot equals 0.
And that's your first
trivial equation of motion.
But it is an equation of
motion, because this body
has a true degree of
freedom in that direction.
That's really the point.
Don't confuse trivial
results because there's
no external forces
with constraints.
It's unconstrained
in the x direction,
or in the y direction
the way I've set it up.
So I think you're
safer if you do just--
say the torques or the forces
in that direction are 0
and you write it down.
Let's look at this problem from
the point of view of Lagrange.
It's also equally
simple, the Lagrange,
except for the
generalized forces.
Actually, Lagrange
is harder because you
have to think your way
through the generalized forces
in this problem.
And I got myself in a
pickle with this problem
and I spent hours
trying to figure out
a good explanation
of a conundrum I
ran into with the
generalized forces.
So let's look.
I'll tell you what
that was in a second.
Let's look at Lagrange.
So you need T. And we're
pretty good at this now,
I with respect to g
zz, theta dot squared.
That's your rotational
kinetic energy.
1/2 mx dot squared
plus y dot squared.
Translational kinetic
energy associated
with the center of mass.
Notice this is with
respect to the center
of mass.
How about v?
Potential energy
in this problem?
Any?
It's all 0's, right?
There's no springs.
There's no gravity in this
plane, operating in this plane.
So this is 0.
This problem's going to
be particularly simple.
So in the theta direction
here, this derivative
with respect to Q dot
gives us Iz theta dot
and the time derivative of
that zz theta double dot.
T with respect to
theta-- nothing.
V with respect to theta?
Nothing.
And on the right hand side,
we need to get Q theta here.
And the other equation,
it's the x equation.
Well, actually, we
can have x and y.
So what about the x equation?
Derivative with
respect to x dot?
I get an mx dot, time
derivative, mx double dot.
And with respect to y.
The thing about Lagrange, if
you can do Lagrange, just write
down the total expression
and just crank it out,
because if you say, oh,
well, I know this is trivial,
then you're actually
employing some information
from the direct method.
If you're saying, I know the sum
of the forces in this direction
is 0.
So when you straight out
in applying Lagrange,
you can do it without any
reference at all to Newton.
So in this case, we just blindly
clunk along and we say, well,
what's the derivative now
with respect to y dot?
Will I get an my dot time
derivative y double dot.
This derivative would be 0.
This derivative is 0.
And over here I get Q1.
Now I'm left-- so the left hand
side of Lagrange equations--
remember, you just add
these terms together.
And these are going to be
our three equations of motion
that result. And now
the remaining work
is to get these three
generalized forces.
Let's go back to our picture.
If we had lined it up
like this, and now we
give it a general little
virtual displacement delta
y, how much work gets done?
None.
And so you suddenly realize,
oh, I went to a lot of work
for nothing here.
This equation is trivial.
Nothing happens there.
And so now it's reduced
to doing the Qx and Qy.
So just to give
us some practice,
let's do Q theta and Qx
the rigorous kinematic way.
I'm going to draw the
general picture here,
because this is where I
got myself into trouble.
You're working
along on a problem
and then something doesn't
quite work for you.
I had set this problem to
do generalized-- to compute
the generalized forces.
And I set it up looking like set
it up like this so theta is 0.
It's lined up like that.
And I started thinking
about, then generalized,
my little virtual
displacements, and I
got into a conceptual problem
that I couldn't sort out
for a while.
And I'll work it into
the explanation here.
So I'm going to set
this up more generally.
I have an angle theta
here, and this is my F1.
So to do this by
this kinematic way,
I need to find the
position vector.
Here's a point-- I'm
going to call it D,
and this is my point
G, and here's O.
So I have a position
vector going to here--
it's RG; and a position
vector going to here-- that's
R of D with respect to G; and
a position vector from here,
and that's RD in O. And RD in O
is RG in O plus RD with respect
to G. I can write that.
They're vectors.
So I'm going to need those.
So what is RG in O?
Well, I have this
coordinate system.
It's going to be some XI plus
YJ in the inertial frame.
And then RD with
respect to G-- I
need to have some kind of
a coordinate system that
rotates with the body.
So I'll call this
y1, and this x1-- how
it's rotating with the body.
So now, this one down here is
minus R in the j1 direction.
So that's the position of this
point D with respect to O,
written as the sum
of two vectors.
And I'm eventually going to
need to be able to express
this j1 in an inertial frame.
So here's just this
little vector j1,
and I need its components
in the J and I directions.
So it's made up of a piece
like that, a piece like this,
and this angle here is theta.
So little j1-- so
I can converge.
I can move from this unit
vector system to that one
by this transformation.
I'm going to need
that in a minute.
Actually, I'll
invoke it right now.
So my position vector here
is-- the x component is x.
Can't read my plus.
I crossed out a plus and minus,
so I got to sort this out
carefully here.
Is this right?
What do you think?
Laura, what have I done wrong?
So this is the plus I direction.
This piece here
is-- so minus sine
theta in the I plus cosine theta
in the J are the components.
So I'm missing a
minus sign there.
OK.
So I want to collect
the I pieces together.
So I have an X in
the I, and I have
a minus R minus sine theta.
So, plus R sine theta--
this is the I contribution.
And then over here I have
a Y and a minus R cosine
theta in the J. Then I have
this vector all worked out
in my inertial frame.
So now I can say
that-- remember, Qj dot
dR-- it's a sort of virtual
deflection for the jth
contribution.
So in this case, I'm interested
in, say, the 1 in the-- which
one should we do
first-- The x direction.
So this is the F1 in the I dot
derivative of RD with respect
to x delta x.
But now I have an--
I can work this out.
I can figure this
one out directly now,
because I have an
expression for R--
that vector-- in terms of
one set of unit vectors,
and I can take the
derivative with respect to x.
And the only x that
shows up in here
is this, so the derivative
is pretty simple.
It's just 1.
So this is F1I dot I delta x.
So this tells us
that Qx equals F1.
No great surprise.
We knew the answer
to that from before.
And I-- oh, I made a mistake.
What didn't I-- I
was mixing the two.
I did a simplification
when I did the direct one.
Is F1 in the I direction?
So F1 has components.
Vector F1 has a magnitude F1
times cosine theta I plus sine
theta J. And so
down here, I need
to put those in and
take the dot product.
So the only dot product that
will matter is the I component.
This is going to be
F1 cosine theta I
dot this, which we know
this gives us just and I.
So I'm leaving out the J piece.
So I end up here
with F1 cosine theta.
Does that look right?
So here is your theta.
Here is your-- this
is F1 cosine theta.
So for our coordinate system
that's squared up like this,
it's only that term that's
in the F1 direction,
and this would
come out correctly.
Now
And if we let-- if we now
reorient our coordinate system
so that theta is 0, then this
would just turn out to be F1.
If you can see that this is
F1 cosine theta without going
through all the work,
what's Qy for this system?
Sure.
F1 sine theta.
We won't go through
all the work,
but you go through
the same taking
the derivative-- in this
case, the derivative of R
with respect to y, and
then dot it with F,
and you get F1 sine
theta in the J direction.
So there's Qy.
Now, the problem I ran
into, conceptually,
is around this other piece.
So Q theta, the virtual work
done in the theta direction,
we know has to do with rotation.
And that is going to
be sum F1 dot-- now
this is the derivative of RD
with respect to theta delta
theta.
So RD is here, and it's indeed
a function of theta, right?
And so I can take a derivative
with respect to theta,
and I'll get derivative
of that R sine theta term,
and I'll get a derivative
of the R cosine theta term.
But here's how I got
myself in trouble.
It took me-- and this
is the sort of thing
that happens to all of us.
You're working a problem,
throw in a simplification,
and then something doesn't work.
Well, what if you had
oriented the axis, initially,
so that the force is aligned
with x and perpendicular to y?
Then this theta
angle is 0, right?
And you know, when
you set it up,
you don't end up with-- the
cosine of 0 is 1, and sine of 0
is 0.
You don't end up with the
cosine and sines in there
to take derivatives of.
You just jump to
the simplification,
and you just find out that
you just have R in the J.
There's no R sine theta term.
It's just vanished on you.
And now you need to take that
derivative to do this step.
And I do count with it as huh?
What have I done wrong?
In order to do this
method, you need
to leave it in the sort
of general formulation,
and then let theta be 0 at the
end, if you want to do that.
So if I had then
finished it, I can
do this for this
general problem,
and then let theta go
to 0, and the answer
will come out all right.
So should we do this?
So this is F1 dot this.
So, F1 dotted with
the derivative of R
with respect to theta.
So I get an R cosine
theta in the I,
and the derivative of
this term will be-- well,
the cosine theta
is minus sine theta
times a minus is a plus R sine
theta in the J delta theta.
And I do this dot
product, so I get
the I times the I's, and the
J terms times the J terms.
And it all works out nicely.
Sine squared plus cosine
squared-- you get 1.
And you find out that the torque
doesn't care about the angle.
And does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Absolutely.
I did this on purpose to give
us a little more practice using
this kinematic
grind it out method.
But, for sure, the
intuitive method
would have yielded result
a lot faster here, right?
We would've said, let's have
a little deflection delta x.
What's the virtual work, then?
Well, would have been
F1 cosine theta delta x.
It would be Qx delta x.
Qy delta y would be F1 delta
y sine theta, and we're done.
And the rotation one-- we
would have looked at this
and said, how much-- in a
little motion delta theta-- how
much does this move?
It moves R delta theta
crossed with the F
that it moves through, or dot
product with that distance,
would have given you
F1 R delta theta equals
Q theta delta theta.
So we could have
done it in a minute.
And sometimes, doing
it the hard way
is what will get you in trouble.
I didn't have the cosine
theta and sine thetas
working out in this and I
couldn't take the derivative.
What did I do wrong?
And I finally realized, I
made the problem too simple,
simplified it too soon.
So I wanted to use this
as a stepping stone
to something I meant to
cover perhaps weeks ago.
And there's a
general little lesson
that we can learn from
this, which you've probably
been taught before, but
I'm going to remind you.
Here's a rigid body.
Got some center of mass.
And I've got a force
acting on it here,
just some arbitrary
position and angle.
So that force has
a line of action,
and perpendicular to
that line of action
is a distance, which
I'll call d here.
And we know that
in R cross F, we
can-- this force exerts a moment
about G that would be R cross
F, where R goes
from here to here,
but it's only the component
perpendicular to it.
So we know that this is
going to create a moment.
And I won't draw pictures
yet here for a moment.
This diagram is
the same as-- well,
I could draw the
same peanut here.
It's the same as the following--
a force here, that's F,
and another force at G,
that's F. Equal and opposite,
so it's like adding
0 to the problem.
So I can do that with
impunity, and I still
have my force F down here.
So this problem's
equal to that problem.
But now, this force and this
force, equal and opposite,
cancel one another,
but create what's
called a couple-- a moment that
we can compute about my point G
here.
So these two forces
create just a pure torque,
leaving this as a force.
They're equal and
opposite, so no net force.
But they create a torque
in this direction,
and there's a remaining
force on the center of mass.
So this whole thing
is also, then,
equal to the
equivalent of a torque
around the center
of mass and a force
applied at the center of mass.
And in this case, the
torque would be dF.
This problem is
easier to do if you're
trying to compute generalized
forces than the one we started
with, because now, the
position vector that we need
goes only to the center of mass.
And the general rule for
this-- you have a body,
you have several
forces-- F1, F2, F3.
That's equal to the body
with G, with a F total on it,
and a moment-- a torque-- total.
And F total-- it's a vector--
is a summation of the Fi's.
And T, the torque
total, is the summation
of each of these guys.
Here's G. This has an R1.
Here is an R2.
Here's an Ri to the ith force.
So this is a summation
of the Ri cross Fi's.
So if you sum all the forces and
compute the equivalent torque
about the center of
mass, sum all the forces
and apply it at
the center of mass,
then this problem is
equal to that problem.
So this can come in
handy when you're
trying to simplify problems.
And for this particular problem,
let's draw our hockey puck.
Going to put my force in
the simplest direction here.
But there's my force.
This problem is equal,
doing the same thing here.
It's the same thing as if I
had drew forces like this.
And that gives me an
equivalent problem,
where I have-- this couple
here produces a torque,
and there is a net force
acting on the center of mass.
So this problem is equal
to this problem now.
A torque and a force both
acting at the center of mass,
and the torque is RF1 in the k.
And the force is just F1 in
the positive I direction.
And R-- but now, what
is the little R vector?
If we're going to do
this the kinematic way?
From here to G, this
is R1, I'll call it.
And that's it.
I only-- now I have
everything acting here.
And Qx delta x is F1
dot derivative of R
with respect to x delta x.
But what is R?
It's XI plus YJ.
The derivative of R1 with
respect to x is just 1
in the I, and the derivative
of R with respect to Y
is just J. So this becomes
a trivial calculation.
F1I dot I-- I get Qx
equals F1 delta x.
Then I get Qy is F1, which is
in the I direction dot J is 0.
And I get Q theta-- ah, Q theta.
Now, do I use this expression?
So, I'm not dealing with little
changes in distance anymore.
When you can put rotation--
when you put moments
about the centers of
mass, it's just easier.
This one-- you call
intuitive, but this is just
going to be the
sum delta theta is
equal to the total
torques acting
at the center of
mass dot delta theta.
And in this case, the torque
is in the k direction,
delta theta's in
the k direction,
and this is RF1k dot k delta
theta, which just gives us
RF1 equals Q theta.
So the torque equations you
can derive straight out.
You don't have to
take derivatives.
It doesn't have anything to
do with change in position.
It's just a little
rotation, delta theta.
So it simplifies this problem
and, actually, totally avoids
the conundrum I got into.
If I work everything
about the center of mass
of that rigid body,
the R gets easier,
the derivatives get
easier, and the torque
becomes obvious how it applies.
We'll talk about-- I
have a pendulum in kind
of a weird shape.
But the pendulum has the
following properties.
So that weird shape--
that may be this.
It's got one plane of
symmetry like this does.
And I'm going to put--
what did I do with my axle?
I'm going to put the axis
of rotation perpendicular
to that plane of symmetry,
somewhere not at G,
not at the center of mass--
so, just what I've done here.
I can make any object that
has a plane of symmetry--
if I have it rotate
about an axis that's
perpendicular to that
plane of symmetry,
it becomes a simple pendulum.
And you can write down
with my inspection
what the equation of motion is.
So, how many degrees of
freedom does this system have?
So first of all, then,
is it planar motion?
So it has, at most,
3, and how many--
and it has a pin through
it that doesn't allow it
to move in x or y.
How many constraints is that?
AUDIENCE: 2.
PROFESSOR: 2.
So how many you got left?
AUDIENCE: 1.
PROFESSOR: 1.
So this is a single
degree of freedom problem,
and I've chosen to have
it move about an axis that
is-- is this axis a
principal axis of this body?
Absolutely.
And so, if I ask you, what's the
mass moment of inertia of this?
If I gave you Izz about G for
this thing, and this distance,
what would you tell
me the mass moment
of inertia about the pivot is?
I'll give you this.
What's the rest of it?
Not a G. You've got
some distance here,
which you're given--
L, we'll call it.
Correct.
So, parallel axis--
remember, ML squared.
So we know that that's true, and
the G is over here someplace,
and this is this distance L. And
what's the equation of motion
for this?
And gravity acts.
No damping for now.
What's the equation of motion?
Right off the top your head.
You've done enough of these.
I'll give you one
minute think about it.
We'll figure out the equation
of motion for this problem.
I highly recommend you
don't do the Lagrange.
Somebody give me their
equation of motion.
So, what method would
you choose to use?
Simplest one you could think of.
Direct?
About what point?
AUDIENCE: Around A.
PROFESSOR: About
A. And what do you
say is-- what
equation do you apply?
General equation.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] It's
just AIzz [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that would
be part of the answer.
And the equation-- remember,
I wrote a list of them-- 1, 2,
3 over there.
Which one do you use?
AUDIENCE: You just
use the second one.
PROFESSOR: Just a
second one, right.
And do the nuisance
terms go away?
Point A's not moving.
So some of the torque
is equal to dHdt,
and it's H with
respect to A, right?
So that's H, right?
d by dt Izz with respect
to A theta double dot k
equals the sum of
the external torques.
And the rest of the problem is
finding the external torques.
What's the free body
diagram look like?
So, here's the object, possibly
A and Rx, and an Ry, and an Mg.
Those are your possible--
that will set your free body
diagram, right?
So here's the Mg down.
What's the torque that
gravitational force
puts on this object
with respect to point A?
R cross F, right?
R cross F into the board.
Is that positive or negative?
And what's the link to this R?
Well, from here to here
is, I guess-- oh, that
is L. So the length of this
side and that triangle?
L sine theta?
L sine theta cross Mg.
And it is positive or
negative-- what did we decide?
Looks like it's-- this is
positive theta xy system.
It gets negative minus MgL
sine theta, and we're done.
So, generically-- and this
is also in the k direction,
so we can drop the k's now.
We have our equation of motion
Izz theta double dot plus MgL
sine theta.
Is there any then single degree
of freedom pendulum made out
of a rigid body, and
rotating about an axis
that is a principal axis that
has that equation of motion?
Any of them, no
matter what the shape.
If you can rotate it
about a principal axis,
and not through G,
because if you put--
what's the natural frequency
if you run the axis through G?
What's the torque?
0.
Nothing happens, right?
It doesn't want to do anything.
But as soon as it's not through
G, then the things oscillates.
And that's because this is
now a differential equation.
And I need to say
this equals 0 here.
There's no other forces.
If you've got a damping
force, then it would show up.
But this is a generic,
undamped equation
of motion for any single
degree of freedom pendulum
rotating about one of
its principal axes.
And if the body
you're shown or given
has a single plane
of symmetry, then you
can figure out one
way, immediately,
that you know this will--
that equation applies.
An axis perpendicular to that
plane of symmetry is a pendulum
and it is that equation.
And the i respect to A you can
get from simple parallel axis,
if you're told what i
with respect to G is.
Questions?
I'm going to put up two
additional problems.
And I'm not going to solve them.
We're going to talk about them.
You're going to tell me how
you would go about doing them.
And they wouldn't be
bad problems for you
to practice on.
And you've actually seen
both of them before.
So, the first one-- pulley
rotating about that fixed axis.
And this is that thing
we call Atwood's Machine.
How did I draw my coordinates?
So I have my Izz about G.
It's sum M3 kappa squared.
You're given the radius of
gyration of this pulley.
So that's its mass moment
of inertia about the center.
And you know R. You
could specify a theta.
And we have a pair of masses--
start off like this, M1, M2.
And this, now-- so I've
going to say, no slip.
And this rope goes over the
pulley, no slip, initially
stationary.
I let go.
I want an equation of
motion for this system.
So how many is
it-- first of all,
is it a planar motion problem?
OK.
How many rigid bodies?
How many potential
degrees of freedom?
AUDIENCE: None.
PROFESSOR: None.
How many do you
think they really
are going to end up with here?
How many do you expect to find?
How many necessary
coordinates are you
going to need to completely
describe the motion?
I see some 1's going up.
Everybody believe that?
Lots of constraints.
We're not going to
let this-- we're
constraining this to
move in-- only allowing
it to move up and down.
These can't rotate, so
there's one for each.
These can't go in this
direction, so two more.
This can only rotate,
no translations.
So you end up with 1.
And finally, there's
this no slip condition,
which means that
R theta equals x,
and that's one final one that
you'd need to write down.
So if you had that,
gotten this far--
find the equation of motion.
What method would you use?
So, your choices are here--
direct method, Lagrange.
Think about it.
How would you-- what's
the easiest way for you to
do this problem?
Maybe an ancillary question
is, how many ways can you
think of that you
could do this problem?
How many different
approaches could you use?
So, how many ways can you think
of doing this problem, Kristen?
I'm just picking on her, but--
AUDIENCE: I'm not Kristen.
PROFESSOR: Give me
an answer anyway.
AUDIENCE: OK.
I think you could do two,
but I would choose Lagrange.
PROFESSOR: You would want
to do it by Lagrange.
Helen, how else could you do it?
If you did it by Lagrange,
got the answer, and said,
I want to check it,
what would you do next?
AUDIENCE: The direct method.
PROFESSOR: Direct.
But where would do apply?
Would you use torques?
Would you use forces?
How would you go
about doing this?
AUDIENCE: I would use torques
about the center of the pulley.
PROFESSOR: Torques
about the center.
We did that.
I mean, I worked
that-- I actually
did this problem by that
method earlier in the term.
Torques about A.
Let's have the pivot.
Works fine.
Actually, it's pretty efficient.
So, Lagrange or torques
about A. You only
need-- there's one
degree of freedom, right?
How many equations do you need
to write to do this problem?
Just one.
So the sum of the torques about
A will give you the answer.
Lagrange equation will
give you the answer.
That's a good problem
to practice on.
Another problem--
this is not very big.
It's basically this problem.
This is just-- you've seen this.
I'm sure you've been shown this
in physics and stuff before.
This is the falling
stick problem.
You can't set this up
without having some friction.
So there's definitely
friction on the table.
But until it hits,
it's doing some things.
And so, there's two
problems that you
could set up and try to do.
One is the problem with no
friction-- frictionless table.
And then, you could
allow friction.
Tricky thing about
allowing friction
is-- you think there's
a normal force.
So let's say our usual friction
model is-- the friction force
is mu times the normal force.
Does the normal force change
with time in this problem?
So, standing up, what's
the normal force?
Mg, right?
And the sum of the forces
in the vertical direction
is mass times acceleration
in the vertical direction.
And what are the-- if
you draw a free body
diagram of this problem--
so let's draw it now.
Here's my-- if there's
no friction force,
I still-- without
friction force,
I still have a normal
force, and I still
have Mg pulling down here.
So the sum of the
forces in the y
certainly have a
minus Mg plus N equals
the mass times the acceleration
in the y direction.
And if you solve for N,
do you-- then the issue--
my question is, does
this remain constant?
Depends on whether or not
ay remains constant, right?
Do you think the acceleration
in the y direction of this thing
will change as it goes
more and more horizontal?
There's some nods, up and
down, and left and rights.
I think it's going to change.
For sure, you can't assume
that it won't change.
So you have to
assume it'll change.
And that means N-- this
normal force becomes
a function of time, which
makes certain ways of doing
this problem a little harder.
So how many ways?
Let's say the friction-- let's
do a, no friction, and b,
with friction.
No friction-- first of all,
is it a planar motion problem?
Yeah, we can do that.
So, at most three
degrees of freedom.
How many does this one have?
Work this one out.
Figure out how many degrees
of freedom this problem has.
How many separate equations
do you need to come up with?
So, you decide what
your-- let's say
we're going to use Lagrange.
What would your
generalized coordinates
be to do this problem?
So, problem a-- no friction.
How many generalized
coordinates?
How many degrees of freedom?
How many generalized
coordinates do you need?
I heard a three.
I hear one.
Somebody give me two.
I got a two.
All right.
Obviously a good question.
So, at most there can
be three, because we've
agreed that it's planar motion.
Does this problem
have any constraints?
Where?
AUDIENCE: The bottom of
the line can't move the y.
PROFESSOR: So it can't
move in the y direction.
So if any part of a body
can't move in-- translate,
then there's no translation
in that direction,
pure translation of the
body in that direction.
So there's a
constraint in the y,
if we draw a
coordinate system here.
Constraint in the y.
True.
So we're down to two.
Are there any other constraints?
AUDIENCE: I would say that,
yes, because the upper line--
PROFESSOR: No, no, it's not
leaning against the wall.
This is just a skip.
This is the problem.
So it definitely can't
move through the table.
So it's constrained in y.
We've got that so now that
leaves us, at most, two.
Are there any other constraints?
How many say no?
How many say yes?
If you say yes, you've
got to tell me what it is,
but I don't see any others.
So we're left with two.
We need two coordinates.
What might we pick here?
What would you pick?
You're now confronted
with this problem.
Do you have
rotational-- if you're
going to use Lagrange do you
have rotational kinetic energy
in this problem?
You're probably going
to need an angle.
What else would you need?
So we're going to need
an angle for sure.
Say it again?
AUDIENCE: The height
of the center of mass.
PROFESSOR: You're going
to need the height
of the center of mass.
Yeah, you're going to need a
potential energy expression,
but we've decided
that y is constrained.
So you can't have
a theta and a y.
Let's make this our theta.
What else is there?
AUDIENCE: x.
PROFESSOR: x.
You're going to need an x.
So our generalized
coordinates are
going to be an x and a theta.
But you do need to be able to
write down a potential energy
expression, and it
involves motion in the y.
So what do you do?
Right.
So what's the
height of this thing
is-- above the ground-- is sum
L over 2 cosine theta equals y.
Something like that, right?
And I might have a-- depending
on whether you make--
I haven't thought this through.
Whether or not it's xy
this way or xy that way,
theta might be plus or minus.
This could be-- there
might be a sine in there.
But basically, this is--
theta and y are constrained.
If you know one,
you know the other.
So you do your potential
energy expression this way.
Now we've gotten that far.
We know we need two coordinates.
We're going to use x and theta.
But now you have to
decide what method to use.
Direct method using one
of these, or Lagrange?
What would you do?
How would you go about it?
It's a quiz.
You got 20 minutes
to finish, and you
want to do this in the
safest, quickest possible way.
What would you try?
And this is the realistic
situation, right?
Next Tuesday.
What do you trust
yourself to do the most?
It's probably what you ought
to do in a quiz situation.
Anne, how many ways can
you think of doing this?
How many ways could
you do this, Rob?
AUDIENCE: Two.
PROFESSOR: Two.
Any way.
Direct, indirect,
what would you use?
Where would you
choose to-- you're
going to need a torque
equation to do this problem,
if you use direct.
Where would you take
your torques about?
Think about that.
For this problem, if you're
doing the direct method,
where are you going to
compute the torques?
About what point?
So you can do it
about that-- you
could call this point A here.
And what equation
would you-- now
you've got to use that
equation that's got
the problematic
terms in it, right?
But it's all right.
You can punch those
through and do it.
That will work.
And if you use Lagrange?
You've got to be
able to figure out
the potential and kinetic
energy, and so forth.
So could all of you
do this by Lagrange?
This is a good one
to go practice on.
It's not that hard.
Do it.
It's a good practice problem.
Now add friction.
So, the b problem.
It now has friction.
Can you-- I don't think--
is Lagrange a good choice
if it now has friction?
I think it's got a problem, and
I'd be careful using Lagrange
if it had friction.
Not that-- Lagrange
is perfectly--
it is certainly valid.
It's just hard.
Why is it hard?
Well, yeah, it might
be hard to find.
What do you need
to know to-- so,
are there any external
non-conservative forces
in the problem with friction?
AUDIENCE: Friction.
PROFESSOR: Friction.
You're going to have to
figure out the friction force.
And to figure out
the friction force,
you're going to have
to apply direct method.
No other way.
You are going to have to
apply some direct method to do
this problem, no matter what.
So you can't just
say-- Lagrange is not
going to bail you
out and not have
to solve some of
the F equals ma,
and torque, and
those sort of things
to figure out what friction is.
So there are problems that
Lagrange-- isn't all as simple
as we sometimes
make it out to be.
All right, I've run a
couple minutes over.
Thank you.
We'll see you in
class on Tuesday.
We'll do some more review.